baseball hall of famer from fox sports
and
an emmy award winner congratulations on
that
john smoltz well thank you very much and
i want to say
happy birthday to you thank you sir i
appreciate that john
are you uh are you north of the
champions tour
[Laughter]
um well i'll answer it this way uh i'm
just a couple weeks
apart from your uh your booth mate on
fox
joe buck and i aren't too far apart so
okay does that answer your question
yeah that does i have my aarp card if
that makes any
so yes i am i am north of the champions
line is that like the mendoza line of
life
pretty much you know that that was the
uh you know short of my big league
career wanted to pitch as long as i
could my next goal was
literally to turn 50 so i could at least
find out if i could play on the
champions tour right that was the next
goal
got a chance qualified haven't been
you know really good lately but yeah 50
was huge for me
so hopefully it's you know going to be
huge for you
well i appreciate that john greatly
appreciate that um let's get into what's
going on in
in baseball what do you make of the
uh i guess mlb tsa checkpoints
being set up for for pitchers these days
yeah you know
um a lot of things that happened in the
game i i can't go back to when i was
playing and there were some abrupt
changes that we had to deal with and you
know at first you're like ah this is
just a little bit much but then it goes
away and you're used to it i think the
same will be said here i mean the optics
of course are a lot different than
anything we've ever seen but there's
layers to it that people forget
that's kind of led up to this right
three years ago so much talk about the
baseball
pitchers were complaining about how
slick it was and
they were getting blisters and of course
we were seeing balls come out of the
park at a
unbelievable rate and going farther than
we've ever seen before
so that being the backdrop you know time
went on and
certain things developed technology and
science obviously is
is where it is and through technology
you could then
get your kind of visible look at what
spin rate we never talked about spin
rate
ever until recently in technology so
that has been kind of
unearthed you know some scenarios that
when you look at the game today people
talk about what
lowest batting average ever most
strikeouts you know we talk about things
that
we typically have seen an increase over
time so
long-winded answer pitchers got to a
point where to grip a baseball throw a
baseball
and know where it's going this kind of
evolved now in spring training
there was a warning issue that this was
coming now whether or not anybody
believed it was coming or not
that's why we're where we're at now i
think in two weeks
it will be a non-issue i think during
this period you'll see the
evidence of two things confidence more
for the hitters
and uh a lesser rate of strikeouts and
certainly more often
so you know is it the perfect scenario
probably not but it's something that
everyone
at least at this time of the year should
not have to deal with that kind of stuff
when you're talking about the summer you
know the grip
and and the heat and the sweat and and
and the rosin that's available for you
so i mean it's but
it's been a rule for a long time exactly
it has been it's been there for a long
time john and it's just
um but but it got out of hand i think
everyone can agree on that you even hear
garrett call and scherzer say yeah let's
get spider tack out of the game and
you're hearing about clubhouse
guys who put together like coca-cola and
this concoction and that concoction
making their own special concoctions and
it got out of hand
and it was so obvious too uh that where
everyone could see it
and it was so blatant that something had
to be done like this
but my problem is now it took all of two
days for girardi who's a catcher
to call out scherzer and have him
checked in the middle of an
inning for because he's going to his his
head and you know
anybody knows that you know the that
scherzer who's in the players
association would be insane
after being checked to do something with
his hair and
in that he still does need something to
go moisture with the rosin like everyone
knows that
and so like what are we doing you know
like it it's it's kind of out of control
in that regard
yeah i think that's going to be more
isolated and honestly you know not
having followed that situation or that
game at that moment right now dude
there's probably a little bit of gains
in the ship to try to
throw off one of the best pitchers in
the game it didn't work
if that was one of the side effects of
it but um
you know when i think about how this
thing has uh
developed and and where we are with
with like i said some of the numbers um
pitchers are not going to forget how to
throw
pitchers are not going to forget how to
spin a baseball will it be at the kind
of technology rate that we're seeing
probably not but you know at the same
time hitters we're not throwing a beef
about the highest velocity ever in the
game making sure that they're not
getting hit
a lot right but consequently the hit
batsman rate went way up
even though we had this kind of
substance so
um look i i i'm gonna lean towards the
pitchers three years ago i haven't held
a baseball in nine years thankfully
because when i do my shoulder hurts
i don't want my shoulder to hurt and so
i gotta trust that they felt three years
ago the ball was definitely different
than it is today
and i was you know i i remember last
game i pitched a regular season
for the saint louis cardinals in
cincinnati the ball was a slick
there wasn't wasn't rubbed up i had no
chance of being
executing pitches i kept telling the
umpire look this is someone's
i don't want to hit anybody i can't feel
the baseball okay i think i threw about
25
baseballs back in the course of my
eventual grand slam and seven runs that
i gave up
you know we protested the game nothing
came of it i bring all that up because
when that feeling happens to a pitcher
there you're usually there's nothing you
can do and so
um you know to the degree of where we
are today
everyone would agree it's been way too
much technology and science has taken it
over the top and that's why i think this
won't be much
to do about nothing once we get past
this kind of
i guess you would say interesting optics
uh for the first week
john smoltz here on the rich eisen show
is there a substance that can be
talked about pictures management
um get it all together and that that's
put on the mound here
and that this is something that is just
a an approved
concoction that allows hitters to feel
like they're not going to get hit and
pitchers feel like they can get a grip
on the ball i mean and that fans can sit
here and think that
that that like when i'm watching all
this chapman have trouble finding the
strike zone last night and him just
going getting so angry and upset and i'm
sitting there thinking is he angry and
upset at himself
or is he angry and upset about the fact
that he doesn't have see any any sort of
feel on the baseball and he's angry at
the situation
you know what i mean so yeah i hope so
because you know not everybody has the
same
uh ability to sweat like i i played with
guys who sweat so much it was cold and
then there's guys who's you know like
for me i had
the driest hands in the world and when
it was warm it was awesome but when it
was cold in chicago or
it was terrible i i i had some of my
worst games
so i hope we can get to that point look
i know we don't want to do copycat kind
of stuff in the game we want our game to
be innovative and all that
but you know i've always said the ball
in japan comes out of the package
with some tacky and it's there's no need
you know they have a different ball than
we do
forever the umpires used to rub up the
baseballs and
there was kind of no issues back then
now it's subject to the home club and
the umpires don't rub up the baseball
and you got all those things and all
those
scenarios i i think people don't
understand though how difficult it would
be
if you ask batters hitters to go up to
the plate with no
no no gloves and no pine cart i mean
yeah it's a bat you're holding on to it
you should be able to hit but the feels
not there and it would there would be no
way they could hit
it at the rate when they have gloves and
pine tar which is
okay for hitters so your points well
taken and hopefully
there's that ability to to not get this
technic technical scientific super edge
nobody wants to be there no one wants to
have that edge
realistically and morally to where it's
such an unfair advantage
um and and i think the numbers kind of
indicated where
the game was going offensively and you
know to this point you could say
hey at least there's some light at the
end of the tunnel well of a little
better balance
because god knows we don't want to move
the bat mound back two feet that'll be
the worst thing that ever happens
um so this is a better compromise and
then
before we go here john smoltz uh we're
we are seeing
two pitchers perform in a manner that is
all time
um and degrom being one jacob degrom
being one
with the mets and how he is performing
and how he throws and what gas he brings
as well as
his ability to hit too and uh uh then
there's otani
who is a unicorn what are what are your
thoughts on these two guys
and and what we can expect of them not
just this year but but long term what do
you think
yeah i make no bones about it i did
jacob de bruyne de graham's uh debut for
moby network when he when he come up and
chase the yankees
i've been known to make some kind of
outrageous statements that don't by the
way turn into two
too many outrageous statements they end
up being kind of in line with how i
think
in my opinion but i said he'd be the
best pitcher the mets have ever seen
um when he made his debut that's how
much i fell in love with a guy that
i thought could mature into one of the
best and he is the most dominant picture
that we've seen in maybe ever and so
that being said if he stays healthy
of course the mets are always in the
conversation of oh you don't want to
play the mets if they get to the
postseason and stay healthy
having said that i'm going to give you
another outrageous statement about
ohtani
ohtani is a special player that you know
i think everyone's rooting for but the
reality of
how long how much longer can this not
take away from each great talent that he
has i will say this about ohtani
and again when i saw him um you know
come into the league i didn't think he
could stay healthy in the beginning
because the task he was trying to pull
off was monumental and he needed time on
both sides
both from a pitching side and from a
hitting side you combine the both
and he's had this super kind of freakish
um
athlete that i hope we continue to see
but
he if all he did was pitch he would be
on the trails of a jacob the ground
he's that good he has that kind of stuff
that he has wiped out dominant number
one a stuff
that that's the angels need that so bad
so
hypothetically if they got to the
postseason and he had to pick and choose
what's the greatest asset for that club
based on their pitching needs the
greatest asset for me is his pitching
ability
he had no headers he had no header stuff
yesterday but the ability to kind of hit
and take away some energy
from doing both at a high level you
could tell he was tired you could tell
he would be drained and yes offensively
he didn't do as well that game
but that's my point like you have this
unbelievable talent
but his arm for me is so unique
that i don't know he'll he'll be given
the opportunity to reach that level
because of the dual job that that you
know he enjoys doing and
they're showcasing do you see his
reaction to getting checked he seemed to
like enjoy it
you know it was just like okay yeah him
and degrom too they're like okay sure
you know yeah and i think that's some
most of what everybody
knows is coming so you know i
look i'll be shocked if things come down
and change
and people go back to it but you never
know anymore
um i was shocked we still have ped
failures but
i i i like the direction of of how
everyone's handling it we had an
isolated situation that you talked about
i don't think we'll see many more of
those
and um you know we're headed towards the
all-star game to showcase some
incredible talent but man shohei
home run derby you know the fact that
that
you know how i feel i think pitchers are
the best athletes in the world anyways
we're just finally coming around to
people getting a chance to see it and
then before i let you go all around the
subject of the good stuff here
how pleasant uh and enjoyable and
intense has
the nl west turned into here how fun is
this yeah sure
guys look i if i'm if i'm in that
giant's locker room i'm having the time
my life having everybody in the world
like
myself uh talk about the padres and the
dodgers right we're just kind of
skidding along here under the radar
they've been fantastic i really thought
the west before the year started had a
chance to get two wild card teams didn't
know what that would be based on the
bottom half of the west
typically is not and it wasn't going to
be you know
let's just face it arizona's having a
rough year in colorado's in transition
so
it's going to be a fun we keep calling a
two-headed race
but man great job in san francisco for
not just caving to what everybody
thought about your ball club being old
and not having a chance and by the way
you just got the best record in the
national league so
kudos to the giants and gabe kepler i
just love the gamers that the padres are
too
and full disclosure i'm having jake
cronenworth on tomorrow
uh not only because he's a hot hitter
but
you know why i'm having him on tomorrow
yeah mr wolverine i hear you
i knew you'd get a kick out of that john
congrats again on the emmy award it is
so deserved you make me smarter every
time i i listen to you and buck and then
obviously you with mlb and
calling into the show that's a fact i
appreciate it i appreciate it thanks man
you got it right back at you that's john
smoltz baseball hall of famer
emmy winning broadcaster and
also michigan stater right there he's a
big michigan state guy
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here